and that's how you're able with that
state of mind
that's how you're able to sit down with
these racist
kkk members and hear them
and listen to them yeah let me give you
an example of something please do that
actually happens
okay so when when one of these guys
walks into a room
with me and sees me
their wall goes right up because i
am the enemy i am black
just because you're black you are the
enemy absolutely
biles joined the king akk right right
you know i mean
what was the kkk all about the you know
they they they didn't like black people
right i know black members are here
so that wall goes right up when they see
the enemy and they're ready to attack
so i'm sitting there two feet away from
the person
interviewing them and i'm asking you
know how do you hate you know you don't
even know me all you see is this color
my skin
well and then as i pointed out if they
tell you well you know
black people are prone to crime all you
have to do is look at the prison system
they're more blasting than white people
you know black people are
lazy you know they don't want to work
they prefer to scam the government
welfare system
um and black people you know are not as
intelligent as white people
they're born with a smaller brain all
you have to do is there's a few sat
scores mr davis
you know black students consistently
every year they score lower than white
people are these the consistent
talking points of everyone in the kkk
you're prone to violence
you're not as smart as me um
s.a.t scores this kind of thing yes
because yeah that's that's the narrative
that they're they teach their members
when you come in those are the talking
points because when you repeat of enough
times
it becomes the truth wow in their minds
you know one's perspective is one's
reality
all right so i'm sitting there
you know to that so when they walk in
the room and there i am
that wall goes up they're ready to pass
so
usually when you when you're telling
somebody things like that
you know you're talking to your
adversary and and you are calling him
uh a criminal uh lazy being on welfare
and telling him he's not as intelligent
as you are because his brain is smaller
and things like that is that offensive
of course that's offensive
am i offended by it absolutely not wow
but
why why am i not offended by it because
it's not right
yeah exactly why would i be offended by
a lie but too many people let their
emotions get in front of them
wow and then they start pushing back and
and when you push back against a wall
guess what the wall usually wins
all right you know you hit that brick
wall you're not going through it
you know they're not hearing what you
have to say because you're pushing back
they are accustomed to that push back
because they are offending you all the
time
and and so you know that they see they
see somebody who was jewish
somebody who is black somebody who was
muslim somebody who was
gay these are people they don't like or
somebody white with a black person
that's like a race traitor somebody you
know they don't like so they go on the
attack and within 45 seconds
they're getting pushed back so they are
accustomed to that you see their verbal
pushback
or physical so they are accustomed to it
but now guess what
i'm sitting two feet in front of them
listening to them
allowing them to be heard and so
i'm throwing them off their game that
because
they're expecting you to fight they're
expecting you to overreact and you just
how do you actually not you know react
in
a negative way how do you sit there and
take that what is that about you in your
dna
that you're like alright buddy all right
i see what you're saying you're not
talking about me
they're not talking about me and you
have to understand i mean they think
they are
but i know better how do they know me
they just met me five ten minutes ago
now if my mother or father would tell me
daryl you know you know i think you're
prone to crime
no you know you're very lazy and you're
not that smart
if if my parents were telling me that i
might take a little more
you know uh acceptance of what they had
to say because
they brought me into this world they
raised me but not somebody who just met
me
ten five ten minutes ago no i'm not
gonna listen to that i mean i'll listen
to it but it
rolls off my back and plus you gotta
understand my background again
my parents were diplomats you know we go
into foreign countries that have
policies and traditions and laws that
don't
you know merge with our own and my dad's
job
was to foster better relations with the
foreign country
with the us so you have to listen to
those people and listen to them
and try to understand where they're
coming from and then
you know you have these conversations so
here's the key
you cannot convince anybody of anything
when that wall is up all right you need
to lower the temperature
bring that wall down and then they hear
you because when the wall is up there
like this
all right so when i when i am listening
to them
showing them that respect allowing them
to be heard
all right that wall is coming down
and when the wall gets down then they
they feel compelled
to reciprocate and allow you to be heard
because after all you gave them you know
you know that respect and that uh
allowing them to be heard you give them
their platform so now they don't give
you
yours so i could go on the attack at
that point because their wall is down
you don't know nothing you can't you
can't tell me nothing that kind of a
thing
exactly you're the one who's a criminal
because you're the one who's hanging
black men from trees you're the one
walking
walking into black churches and shooting
people and bombing their churches and
burning down their homes
uh you know dragging black people behind
pick up trucks which you naturally don't
say right
right do you ever want to say that do
you ever want to say
yes of course i do but you hold it back
because because what
what because it's true these things did
happen
and they still happen okay yeah so it's
true i could i would be well
to my right to say that all right but no
if i
do that that wall starts going back up i
want to keep the wall down so they hear
what i have to say
so rather than go on the offense i stay
on the defense
and what i say is you know i hear what
you're saying
but please consider this i don't have a
criminal record
nobody in my family has a criminal
record
i have never been on welfare nobody in
my family's been on welfare
i've never measured my brain size but
i'm sure it's the same size as anybody
else's
and as far as sap scores go my
sats got me into college i have a
college degree
now i say that knowing that that person
sitting two feet in front of me
barely made it out of high school if he
did all right
and i know that i have more intelligence
in my little fingernail than he and his
whole clan put together
but i'm not going to throw that in his
face because if i did
that wall goes back up so let me tell
you so
what happens then okay so you know
rather than attack with all those
facts that i have i just defended him
and that because that way he hears them
and he can process them he doesn't hear
anything with him when his wall is up
so i can tell you this for a fact not an
opinion a fact
because years later months later
whatever
when they when they uh renounce that
ideology and give it up and give you
their rubs and hoods and stuff
here's what what i found out has
happened multiple times with these
people
they go home and they think about what
transpired during the day
and they're like damn you know i just
had a three-hour conversation with a
black guy
three hours and we didn't fight you know
we disagreed but we didn't fight
you know and what he said about such and
such you know that makes sense
but he's black uh but but what he said
was true
oh but he's black so they're having this
cognitive dissonance going on
you know they realize something is true
but it came from a black source so that
is not compute
you know and so it leaves them with a
dilemma
and the dilemma is i know this to be
true
so should i disregard his skin color
and believe the truth and change my
direction or should i consider his skin
color and keep on living a lie
that becomes their dilemma and
eventually many of them go the right way
and they believe the truth and they
renounce and they change
there will always be those who will go
to their graves being hateful
racist and violent but see that's why i
say i plant the seed i have the impetus
for them to change themselves i don't
like to say that i converted them i just
gave them a reason to think about it
and they convert themselves and that was
in the introduction that's what i said
is that you're the spark
that that causes them to go back and sit
at home
and be like damn like yeah this guy just
blew my mind he was
he was smart he was cool we got along he
plays the hell out of a keyboard a piano
you can do the twist you can do it all
and i can
[Music]